[music playing]
- There you go that's good.
- Anyway.
- Yeah.
- Keegan-Michael Key and I are
closing in on our extraction
point, but first we've got to
use a diagonal line to descend
a 250 foot Icelandic waterfall.
- That's it.
That's it.
Now keep your legs
down, legs down.
[groans]
- Holy [bleep].
- Have a check out.
Are there seagulls?
I bet there'd be seagulls there.
- There's a baby
seagull right there.
It's amazing.
He doesn't know what the
hell I'm doing here, but--
[laughs] Oh my God.
- Remember, don't look down.
- OK.
I'm going to start lowering you.
Here you go.
[music playing]
- [laughing] Just me and baby
seagull sitting on the cliff
[music playing]
- Look at the power of it.
- Well done, Keegan.
Good job.
Almost there.
Last bit.
- [whoops] [chuckles]
[music playing]
- We said we were going to
get someplace really fast.
That was pretty fast.
- OK.
Time to go and join him.
- Coming off the
waterfall, as I was
going down right to the edge,
I'm like, what are we doing?
And the next thing I
know, I'm just in midair.
But what a view.
[laughing] Whoo!
That was amazing.
You came down really fast.
- Yeah.
Well, it's called hot gloves.
- Oh, you got hot gloves.
Oh, you got hot--
- Good job, though.
- Oh, thanks, man.
Unbelievable.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
- Unbelievable.
- How can we get
around the back of it?
Look.
- That would be amazing, yeah.
- So we're at the
bottom of this now.
Keegan is pumped.
It looks like we might be
able to sneak a little route
around the back
of the flow, which
would be pretty epic to see.
Wow.
There you go.
- It's amazing.
- Like a little hidden
grotto, isn't it?
- Yeah, exactly.
I love the sound it makes
when it hits the rocks.
It's as if it was
planned, you know?
It's completely untouched.
[music playing]
- So that's nature at its best.
- I've never seen
anything like that.
To see the little gulls!
It's so funny to watch
them, like, who is this?
- Yeah.
- It's just-- but I just--
I don't know what it is.
It's just communing
with another life form.
- Yeah.
- You said something
earlier about
you just kind of see
yourself-- nature
is a mirror for yourself.
It's really-- that
really-- that--
I mean, coming down
the side of that cliff
was exciting and exhilarating.
But seeing those gulls?
Like, that was something I never
expected to see in my life,
you know?
And it's just great.
It was amazing.
- It's like, for me
almost, you start
out the journey with the weight
of the world on your shoulders.
- A little bit, yeah.
- And you're finishing it.
I love the way it's
the little things,
like nature, birds, and animals
that lifts your spirits.
- What would have happened
if I just said no no no no,
I can't do that.
Then I wouldn't--
you know, I would
have never seen those gulls.
What would have happened if I
had said no no no, you're cool.
You have the spider.
Like, just do it, Keegan.
What happens if you just do it?
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Well, the stuff we fear
is itself often never
as bad once you face it.
- Exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
- Well, that's an inspiring
message, and you've lived it.
More importantly,
you've lived it.
- I've lived it, right.
Right.
- OK, we're pushing on.